o gol do uruguai
e morreu é e o lado pessoal e quem fala
ao dar que sejam muito bem vindos a mais
de um filho e como isto me pergunte
pessoal eu comprei que outro que
encontrou um modo olha só esse aqui é
muito grande este sim é potente é porque
já vi um vídeo com quem destituiu neste
vídeo que fazer muitos altos e consegui
fazer muita coisa mas o game acabou por
quebrar então eu tive que comprar esse
aqui que é muito mais potente que vocês
vão ver tudo por dentro quando estar na
loja fiquei muito impressionado
olha isso eu acho que vai contar tudo
bem que um touro inspirador na verdade
eu não percebo é como é que isto
funciona mesmo olhando pra isso eu sei
que é por ter vindo como explicar alguns
idade máxima deve atingir os 120
quilómetros por hora 120 mas eu acho que
não vou conseguir atingir a velocidade
aqui porque não vou perder o carro então
vamos tentar manusear e com cuidado e
que tal nosso comando só o banner gozo e
eu acho que o prazo de 25 15
e para este vídeo vejam só temos aqui na
floresta olhe isto não é assombrada tem
muita roupa subir para saltar tem muita
coisa mesmo em cima sabe muita coisa que
eu posso usar tão e situações de fazer
hoje
mas primeiro pessoal muito importante
deixem muito mais que nos trilhos se
vocês quiserem voltar a ouvir conteúdos
que encontrou monte que eu tenho muitas
idéias ok
imaginem só um kadim com o nitro isso aí
não será que saiu por cimentar mas
comentei que só deixei muito mais que
isso não foi inscrito no canal
inscrevemos que eu voltar vou ficar ruim
mas vamos apurar com a rua são só vamos
lá com dívidas que tem 321 o hu já o
show roda
ok agora é só ligar o comando o já me
chama que eu vou voltar aqui o carrinho
a lei é muito importante vou tentar
saltar da mesa e 321 eu vou é isso
essa casa é muito poder vamos lá com 12
horas
op é só vocês não viram que ela tira
olhem eu vou tentar tirar agora klingon
ela vai da bosta 321 vai ou não passa
por mim aqui no meio do mato
ok eu vou tentar explorar com mais
cuidado a lei
eu não sei fazer estas coisas têm tirar
a licença da onu mas desta vez agora
isso está preso
aí é meu eu tenho uma rampa de lima e eu
vou ter de saltar aqui eu vou ter que
soltar esse mesmo tempo tá prefeito
presídio e vai dar um salto muito grande
aqui só vi o mais óbvio 21 acima da
produção das mães produção tá tudo bem
vamos lá ver qualquer coisa nessa altura
de uma peça
eis alto go pro já temos mais e mais
isso que eu próprio vou guardá lo aqui
mas eu acho que o kaká não foi lapso ou
não vou tentar agora esta rampa vamos
ver se consigo saltar melhor
ae olha está novo é muito resistente
eu vou tentar até agora só um objetivo e
eu saltar e calhar tb é esse o objetivo
[Música]
é é a ficou preso através de qualquer
forma mas pelo menos ninguém ficou de pé
mas vamos tentar outra vez vai ter que
sair direito embora agora vai
[Música]
eu consegui a cabo em 2005 é que vamos
tentar um só ter riscado e colocar a
câmera e o caso vai saltar por cima
nesta rampa tudo pode acontecer a câmera
pode entregar pode partir para mil pode
explodir tudo mas vamos buscar o carro
foi doado era o carro passou por cima da
bola pessoal vamos lá fazer então alguns
alvos específicos em imagens para lá
o co
agora vou tentar saltar esta ampla e
fazer um pac
pode não parecer uma rampa e na verdade
acho que não é mas vamos tentar saltar
com o caso e aí vou ficar já olha lá ó ó
ó ó eu fui voltou de 1511 tal foi lá
ainda voltou e agora está preso num rol
de vida sempre foi assim
eu vou buscar o carro sobre a cabeça
não consigo bora lá pessoal agora vamos
para um sítio pela frente com muito mais
campo espero que eu consiga salvar mais
para lá vamos saltar a melhor em campo
que encontrei aqui olha isso muito
grande estamos prontos para lei 3 2 18
o gol ao contrário já agora fazemos ao
endereço não era suposto ter que ir ali
ok eu vou tentar outra vez foram a
segunda tentativa 321 isso correu muito
mal agora eu acho que o problema não
funciona
a hitachi queimado uma coisa elétrica
cheiro a queimado já não funciona mesmo
o óquei preço isto funciona ainda agora
é só colocar a capinha
eu não quero nenhum muito tempo
bora lá então bem pessoal como o nosso
que encontrar um modo se safa nos lift
[Música]
porque tudo bem pensado nisso hilton
andar em um carro mas não só cometi com
o chão olhei sou marcas de grife e ainda
vão jogar mais bola
foi o que precisava da ajuda dele para
sempre onde estava o carro pronto em que
deu em face do tigres o gfk
o amanhã é bom só não justifica porque
construí você já poderão ver o poder
disse que encontrou o outro e agora
precisa da nossa ajuda eu quero fazer
comenta em como eu posso fazer mais
vídeos com este carinho pensar em fazer
nitro em colocar bombas de fumo meu é
fazer uma tampinha toda personalizada
como ferrari e um lamborghini sei lá há
muito e nem que eu posso fazer
então comecei deixei muito lhe quiserem
continuar a ver vídeos do que encontrou
com motor e já sabe só foi inscrito no
canal inscrevam se é isso fique bem até
a próxima